welcome to this virtual meeting
of the council
first may i remind you of some of the
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
members are reminded not to use the
messaging chat
function during the meeting unless it is
to report a pecuniary
non-pecuniary interest or to notify the
chair that you wish to make a proposal
that if you're attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave additionally
you'll be invited to speak and ask
questions by the chair
please await your turn if members lose
connection to the meeting
that they must contact the member
support officer mandy smith
as soon as possible as this is a virtual
meeting
you will not need to stand to address
the chair
and members we are using a new
electronic voting system this evening
and subject to the urgent motion or
notice being approved
the voting will be recorded on the
website
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast
live to the internet and will be capable
of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential
or exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting
you'll be deemed by the council to have
consented
to being filmed by entering this meeting
you're also consenting to being filmed
by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcastings
and or training purposes
the council members of the public
and the press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i will now move to the agenda
apologies for absence thank you chair i
have received apologies for absence from
councillors
holt and councillor dawson thank you
we'll now move to item two declaration
of interest by councillors
are there any declarations of interest
there are no declarations of interest
we'll now move to item 12
on the agenda i've brought this up um
this item
up earlier in the agenda it's the item
about voting
and so enable us to properly work this
meeting
so that we can make the decision before
we have any votes to cast
i have now brought this item up to
become number three
i refer you to the urgent motion on
notice that was circulated yesterday
i would like to vary the order of
business and take this item before item
through on the agenda
council award would you like to move the
motion
thank you madam chairman this
administration has
consistently pursued the use of
technology to provide the public and
press
with an enhanced level of access and
engagement in our meetings
this approach has been crucial during
the kobit 19 pandemic
where we have maintained open
accountable and transparent democracy
by fully embracing virtual meetings
indeed
baba and mid-suffolk district councils
were the first councils in suffolk to
hold fully virtual meetings
open to the public an extension to our
use of technology in virtual meetings
is the adoption of e-voting to replace
the lengthy and cumbersome process of
roll call voting
temporary alterations to the
constitution to allow e-voting have
already been made by the monitoring
officer under delegation
however i firmly believe e-verting is
the way forward for a robust and
efficient means of voting for all of our
meetings
council cabinet and committees whether
virtual or
in person hence i am proposing that the
council adopts e-voting as its primary
means of voting
i have also listened to the concerns
raised by councillors about losing the
current
enhanced level of public access to
voting afforded by the process of roll
call voting
this is essentially the ability of the
public to see how each council of votes
on every item which is something which
we didn't even have
in face-to-face meetings without the
public being present physically in the
meeting room
therefore this urgent motion also
proposes a constitutional change to
enable the publication of a record of
voting at every meeting on the council's
website
to ensure the highest level of openness
and transparency
this will not negate the process for
formally requesting a recorded vote for
the purposes
of the minutes or the statutory
requirement to record the budget vote
formally
so to the motion itself that this
council permanently adopts e-voting as
its primary method of voting
in all meetings and that a record of all
votes cast at meetings of the full
council
cabinet and committees be published on
the council's website with immediate
effect
further that the monitoring officer be
authorised to make the required
amendments to the council's constitution
thank you madam chairman thank you
council award could i have a seconder
please
council john osborne thank you thank you
madam chairman
i'm happy to um second this motion thank
you
thank you we'll now move to the debate
councillors will only be allowed to
speak once for three minutes
and this will be timed thank you
who would like to open the debate that
councillor lindsay
councillor lindsay would you like to
open the debate please
yes thank you uh madam chairman i i am
i had a slight i i don't disagree at all
with the
thrust of this motion and um
and basically support it but i had a a
slight amendment i wanted to add
um is it appropriate to
move that out now um
perhaps yes you can't you can read that
no
lindsay thank you um so it was
to keep the wording as it is um
uh in the motion but in in the
where it says that this council
permanently adopts etc
um uh after the first sentence so
be published on the council's website
with immediate effect
i just wanted to add that immediately
after the vote
during the meeting the monitoring
officer
reads out the names of those voting
against and those abstaining
and then the the motion itself carries
on unchanged from
what council award is proposing in other
words further
the monitoring officer who authorized to
make
the required amendments to the council's
constitution
so i'll just if if it's okay i can
perhaps
to make it simpler for you i've posted
up the line i wanted to add just into
the
chat so people can see it written down
as i know it's difficult to follow
so i've just posted that up into the
chat um
and it it's my thought was was really
that
um um
you you kind of lose the images see i
know the motion says
that the um voting record we put up
immediately on the website
but for people actually in practice we
know that won't be
immediately presumably because someone's
got to do it so
presumably the following day or but
people
members of the public the press who are
attending the meeting
kind of want to know who voted what in
the meeting
so that's and i don't think i think we
as
public elected people want to be ashamed
about the way we vote
um so so that's that's why i've been
inserted that in
thank you thank you council lindsay have
you got a seconder for your
amendment please
um i think council councillor jameson
has his hand up so
i'm hoping he's going to councillor
jameson are you seconding that amendment
uh yes sir madame said yeah i'm happy to
second that amendment
happy with the merchant um put forward
by council award
and i'm happy to second the amendment as
well thank you is there anything you
wanted to say at this stage
no not at this stage now thank you
council award um can i
are you happy with the amendment um no
i'm not
actually a couple of reasons firstly
it's detracting from the purpose of
efficiency
um by having another step which really
frankly is unnecessary if we're going to
publish this information
immediately after the meeting and and
secondly um
there's a certain element of um
scapegoating i think perhaps
uh that could be inferred in it um i
i just don't see that it has any
necessity quite honestly
that the motion as it stands is is
perfectly um
sufficient to um allow evoting
in in as quick and as seamless a manner
as
as it's intended and also to
ensure we have the the visibility and
and democratic accountability that we
wish to intend
um through this motion so no i don't
think it needs any further addition
thank you council award so first of all
we're going to now go
to debate on the amendment in that case
please
would anyone like to open up the debates
that john hinton
please could you open the debate on the
amendment
thank you thank you ma'am chairman well
it my comments repl
question really uh applies to equally to
the amendment and to the main motion
and that is that presumably um
this change to the constitution makes
every single vote a recorded one so why
do we then have to say
that this doesn't affect the recording
of the vote for the budget
and when somebody asked for a recorded
vote because
it's everyone's going to be recorded
vote whether anybody likes it or not
so where's the difference in that and if
it's all about transparency
how come changes to delegated powers and
everything else by
officers are not flagged up when they
occur
so that we have chance to have a look at
them um because that is not very
transparent if other things are
happening behind the scenes
thank you council hinton i'll ask our
monitoring
officer to answer these questions for
you
thank you chair and good evening
councillors uh with regards to the
question about recorded votes there will
still be a requirement for a recorded
vote
in the formal sense so what we're doing
by publishing the outcome of the vote
is not actually taking a recorded vote
which is very technically and very
specifically
for the purposes of recording the vote
in the minutes
so this is a separate record of the
votes cast
rather than a formal uh recorded vote
in the legal and in the constitutional
sense of of the term
um in response to councillor hinton's
second
part of the question chair i would just
like to point out that all officer
decisions
um taken under delegation of a value of
over the 10 000 pounds
must be published on the council's
website in accordance with
the council's constitution and with
legislation
around publicity and um executive
functions
and in regards to urgent decisions that
have been taken under delegation during
this period of the covert 19 pandemic
all of those decisions have been
published on our website and councillors
have received email notification
of those decisions thank you chair
thank you to our monitoring officer
could i come back on that madam chairman
uh what is the difference then between a
recorded vote
and this form of recording it's a bit
like saying what's white is white and
what's black is black it's
they're completely different or you're
implying that they're completely
different whereas in actual fact they
are the same
and when it comes to delegated decisions
once they are made there is no way that
counsellors can
actually challenge them
or disagree with them or represent their
constituents properly
uh in the implementation of them
our monitoring officer will help you
with that again thank you
thank you chair um i'm i'm afraid i
can't put it more simply than
the a recorded vote in the formal sense
and as defined in the constitution and
in legislation
is recorded in the minutes what we are
doing by publishing the result of the
vote
is not a formal recorded vote it is
simply making that information
available to the public to replicate
the access that the public have had
during the roll call vote
i know that that doesn't sound like two
different things but they are two
different things
in terms of of law and procedure
with regards to the delegated decisions
uh
any executive decision taken by an
officer
is subject to the call-in process so
any decision can be challenged by
councillors through the overview and
scrutiny process
thank you chair
thank you councillor mccror
you're speaking to the amendment i'll
remind you please
i am indeed chair um
i have to say and slightly echo the
initial thoughts
of council award here um when i first
came across this
concept and it was brought up to me
sometime this afternoon as a suggestion
my immediate reaction was that well
reading out the 32 names involved
on both sides of any vote or even a vote
on a committee it's going to be a rather
lengthy process and
one of the purposes of carrying this out
was efficiency and
the time saved but there's a much more
important thing about this because
um i i must admit i slightly um
represent the suggestion that i would be
ashamed of my voting at any time
or that i should be ashamed of my voting
i'm quite happy to speak to anything
that i've done
and say what i've done um but there's a
risk here
and it's a significant one of demonizing
members particularly where we're dealing
with controversial
matters perhaps in planning but there
are other areas where the matters can be
controversial
now if you consider this that we are
making a simple binary choice either in
favor of emotion
or against emotion that cannot possibly
encapsulate the amount of
thought and attention to detail given
in a complicated matter such as a
planning decision where the balance can
lie
very easily one way or the other there's
a lot of thought
goes into that before one makes a
decision one way or the other
i don't agree with abstaining it's uh
frankly not the point of our being here
so i have no shame about my votes and i
don't think anybody ever should
but i don't like the idea that we're
going to be sort of effectively naming
and shaming people
um in these circumstances i'd no
particular wish to provide fodder
for a series of facebook posts there's
quite enough of that goes on in the
first place
so i won't be supporting the amendment
to the motion i will be supporting the
motion
thank you council mccraw councillor beer
talking to the amendment please
kill madame chairman uh yes
um well i i quite um liked what uh
councillor mcgorr just said
i also would take um exception to the
fact that
um uh one should not be ashamed as to
how they vote
i don't like abstentions i i don't
believe and particularly
when you're elected to like a planning
committee
that you can sit on the fence and not
come down on one side or the other
you're there to make a decision
and sometimes it can be unpopular i
understand that
um so abstentions i'm not at all happy
with
but going back to the amendment
councillor lindsay
did say i believe i'm right that um
[Music]
go on to those who have voted
the opposite way and those who have
abstained
well i think if you went down that road
you'd need to also
list the people who voted for it so that
you had all three of them in front of
you
but madame chairman i do feel that the
original
um emotion does allow us
and i think the officer has said it uh
to actually make available
by the end of the meeting a list of
how all members have voted on on the
particular item
and that could be sent out to all the
members um
it's then made available at county
council you can leave the council
chamber
and you can see on a screen in in the
members area
as to how everybody voted it's all
recorded there and usually
up quite quickly after the meeting um
so i don't have a problem uh with
electronic photon
i do think it should be made available
as quickly as possible after the meeting
to all members and that can also then be
picked up by the public if they so wish
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor beer
councillor hardaker
well i'm here um i agree with the
principle of
robert's amendment and i will be voting
for it but i think we're kind of missing
a trick here which is that someone
somewhere
presumably one of the officers has on
their screen the results of electronic
voting
we're already doing videos by video
meetings by youtube whether or not the
real meetings or not
we already have the ability to share
powerpoint presentations so account the
real time screen of the votes come in
just be shared on the screen
it seems technically simple to me and
then
anyone watching youtube video can just
see it
i'll ask our monitoring officer to
answer that that question thank you
thank you chair and councillor hardaker
makes a very good point and something
that we have explored
um however the system at the moment is
limited
in terms of that display the officer
controlling
the uh back end of the voting system
cannot see all of the votes on a single
screen so it wouldn't really work in
terms of
publishing that on the screen in a
virtual meeting
but it is something that we continue to
work on because obviously an ideal
solution would be able to
to flash up the result of the vote at
the end
of the voting process so it's something
that we continue to work on chair but
technically
is not possible uh right away
thank you um
does that answer your question
councillor hardaker
yes thank you thank you uh council
malfeasy
thank you madam thank you madam chairman
um i'm at one with councillor mccraw
um i'm not ashamed of the way i vote
but i certainly don't wish to be party
to naming and shaming
my fellow councillors so i will not be
voting for the amendment
thank you
councillor parker
would like to speak to the amendment
thank you yeah thank you madam chair
mine's just really a technical question
it's probably one for the officers but
um
as as this amendment uh isn't actually
uh on uh mod gov uh presumably
ironically
we're gonna have to do this by uh by
manual vote aren't we this this
particular one
um emily can you help us here
yes chair so we do have the capability
to
add amendments to the system um
at the very last minute so officers have
been uh
typing away in the background to add
wording and create a vote so you can
vote on this
amendment electronically thank you yeah
what a wonderful thing technology is
any more questions or any more comments
on the amendment
so if there are no more um questions or
comments on the amendment or debate on
the amendment
um i'll ask um councillor lindsay
to sum up and then i'll go to council
award
council lindsay thank you chairman
and thanks to the officers who i had no
idea i'd
set somebody to work frantically um
writing stuff up
um yeah i think
the only point seemed to be that people
said they weren't
ashamed of how they vote but they didn't
want people to be named and shamed
i don't see how those two statements
tally
um if you're not ashamed about how you
vote
then are you saying that other councils
are ashamed of validate
there's no one's not being named ashamed
if you're not ashamed of how you vote so
i just wanted to point that logical flaw
in your
arguments and i'll leave it at that
thank you thank you councillor lindsay
council award uh yeah
the the only uh other uh point i i'd
wish to make
on on this amendment is that um of
course individual councillors are
perfectly
uh free to say how they're going to vote
um
during the any uh comments they wish to
make in the debate
so um individuals can can quite happily
do that so
uh i i still maintain that this this
amendment is is unnecessary
thank you council award so now we're
going to vote
um on the amendment
so we're going to do that
oh so i'll i'll now ask our deputy
monitoring officer to
take us through that john thank you
chair um
cancers could you please open the vote
in the modern.gov app by clicking the
plus sign in the top right hand of the
screen
and selecting your vote please
and i'm i'm for it but i still can't get
it to come up properly so i can vote
that's fine we can add that manually
afterwards so you can you're voting for
counsellor
yes okay councillor huron
councillor haran
okay councillor creswell can you
indicate how you wish to vote
against against thank you councillor
lindsay
four okay
thank you councillor haran are you able
to indicate how you wish to vote
cancer haran are you are you able to
hear me
councillor haran we can see that you're
still in the meeting are you able to
indicate how you wish to vote
hello john i'm with you at last night
i'm against the motion
thank you the amendment the amendment
yes
yeah okay lovely thank you we will now
tell you those up thank you
sorry mandy i'm not
i voted the wrong way
sorry counselor airs yeah
and i'm because i was trying to fiddle
about with the other
i'm for um i'm
i'm against because i'm for what i'm
council award said
okay councillor we will amend your vote
thank you
so i'm still trying to get sorted out no
problem thank you
okay thank you um i can confirm that the
voting is
25 against the amendment and 4
26 against the the amendment and for
for the amendment thank you chair
thank you jan so the amendment is lost
so we'll now um talk debate
to the original motion thank you
would anyone like to start the debate on
the original motion please
counselor parker would you like to start
the debate please
uh yeah thank you madam chair so i i
suppose the obvious question then
uh therefore is if we are making an
amendment to the constitution
uh specifically for this purpose um
in the uh in the event that we return to
chamber for
uh for physical meetings does that then
require a further change of constitution
madam chair i'll ask our monitoring
officer
thank you chair the wording of the
motion
describes e-voting as our primary method
of voting
therefore there will we will retain the
wording in the constitution that also
allows for
other methods of voting uh such as hands
up voting
by consent of the meeting um or indeed a
roll call vote
if the chairman so requires it thank you
thank you have you got any other people
who want to join the debate
oh margaret mayberry councillor mabry
would you like to
um join the debate yes thank you
um and and thank you to the monitoring
officer for
just confirming this so basically
um we can we still
have our types of voting
that we have currently now
so i'm i wasn't against
this motion but i think from what the
monitoring officer has said
that we're going to have this crossover
of types of voting that
is allowable so why have we got this
motion
well our school monitoring officer thank
you
thank you chair um so at present the
constitution
talks about voting by show of hands or
by the ascent of the meeting to enable
us to conduct voting during
the use of virtual meetings while we're
not able to meet in person
i made a temporary amendment an
alteration to the constitution
under my delegation to allow for
e-voting
uh however i don't think that it would
be appropriate for me to make that
decision permanently to vote
with elect by electronic means uh
without the consent of the council i
don't think it's appropriate for me to
use my delegation to do that on a
permanent basis
therefore this motion does two things it
allows us to adopt e-voting on a
permanent basis
but it also makes that alteration to our
practice
to actually publish the records of the
votes cast
thank you chair
may i come back madam chairman yes
please do
um thank you um uh and thank you to the
monitoring officer for
for that explanation considering that
the council does not anticipate to be
permanently
working in uh in this way i.e
from from home basically for most of us
um and that we are hoping
that covert 19 will cease its um
veracity through the population in the
next few months
um i don't actually see the reasoning
why that this is um an emergency
motion on notice and i will be honest
i definitely was not against it but i'm
now beginning to feel that
i may well be thank you
and my other question is and before
any vote is taken on this i wonder if
council award
would re-read the motion because
um his wording as he read it out was
actually different
to what is written on the emergency
paper
thank you thank you councillor mayberry
um i'll ask councillor walter do that at
the end when he sums up
would anyone else like to join the
debate
does anyone else have anything to add
council mulveezy thank you thank you
madam chairman
um it's just to say that i'm pleased
that the motion has come forward so that
we can
tidy up the constitution um
rather than leave it it is a
a semi-paid employee
sort of thing thank you
thank you cops councilman easy is there
anyone
else who would like to um join in the
debate before we move back to council
award
so in that case uh council award
oh councilman mabry did you want to say
um sorry you can't come back
um you've already um had your
opportunity to speak
sorry councillor mayberry um is there
anyone else who has not spoken who would
like to
join the debate councillor hinton
thank you madam chairman just coming
back to the question that was posed to
the monitoring officer about
when we go back into the chamber can we
does that mean we have to
uh pass a motion to go back to how we
wanted to do it
her answer i found uh rather ambiguous
because it implied that there were three
different systems of voting available to
us and we would then have to decide at
each meeting
or on each vote which one we have to
happen to want to use whether it was
recorded show of hands
or electronic it's a whole thing is
getting a bit of a muddle
we're either electronic or we're not
electronic
or we're manual or we're not manual
we seem to be getting into a right model
as to which one is actually going to be
available to us after kobe 19 allows us
back into the chamber
i'll ask our monitoring officer to
clarify thank you
i think i can also actually if
if i may council ward
yeah um the motion itself explicitly
states
that e-voting
um will be the primary method of voting
for all of our meetings
so unless we want to do anything
different whether we are doing this
virtually
or in the chamber we will be using
e-voting
and um that there's a strong push
uh to use technology as much as we can
so um i i
i'm not sure councillor hinton's
confusion there e-voting is going to be
what we're going to use wherever we are
um is there anything you wanted to add
to the
um emily
and thank you to council award for uh
re-emphasizing the word primary in the
motion
um the reason that the other methods of
voting will exist in the constitution
are of course
as a contingency arrangement should
there be any issues with technology for
example
at a meeting and the recorded
vote provisions have to stay in our
constitution by law
thank you thank you is there anyone else
who wanted to speak otherwise i'll move
now to
council award to read out the motion and
to sum up
council ward would you like to sum up
and to also read out the
motion again for clarification so thank
you madam chairman
uh yes um well i'm pleased uh with
with the debate and and the fact that uh
certainly from the debate um most
members do
appreciate the benefits of e-voting i
know
um in the initial vote on
the amendment we did have some some
gremlins but
it's a matter of uh becoming familiar
with the system uh learning how to use
it it is very straightforward
um and it's just uh i'm sure
something that even by the end of this
evening once we've had several other
votes we will all be
much more proficient at it and
we will all see the benefits of
of this method of voting it is
straightforward
it is quick it is efficient and it does
have
an automatic record of what's what's
been done
in terms of the motion itself i will
re-read it now um
however i did read it verbatim as
you'll see in the your agenda supplement
um
i did not change any of the wording so
the motion is that this council
permanently adopts e-voting as its
primary method of voting
in all meetings and that a record of all
votes cast at meetings of the full
council
cabinet and committees be published on
the council's website with immediate
effect further that the monitoring
officer be authorized to make the
required amendments to the council's
constitution
thank you council award i will now ask
the corporate manager governance and
civic office
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the vote in the modern.gov
app by clicking the plus sign in the top
right hand of the agenda screen
and selecting attendance and voting in
the voting tab the vote for this agenda
item will show
in blue please click on the blue line to
open the vote
thank you
you counsellors to to um indicate how
you wish to vote
counselor airs please oh sorry counselor
as you've just managed to receive your
vote
okay councillor haron i pull the motion
for the motion thank you and councillor
creswell
cancer creswell are you in the meeting
four sorry
four did you hear sorry yes i did thank
you
thank you
okay um thank you councillors
the vote was 29 for the motion and one
against
thank you
thank you the motion is carried council
mccraw
i understand you wanted to raise the
point of order
thank you chair i believe it would help
us carry out the electronic voting in
the future
i'd like to make a suggestion that
officers explore the idea
of having the scroll bar on the
right-hand side of the voting screen
permanently widened in the default
position it's just a narrow line so it
isn't obviously
apparent how you move down the screen if
that were to be a wider scroll bar i
believe it would make life easier for
everybody to carry out these votes
i i think that will be looked in
good evening there was an adjournment of
proceedings
just a few minutes ago because the
live output to youtube had a technical
issue
there were no decisions made and the
meeting was stopped
during this period we will now start
on item three on our agenda
so no points of the meeting have been
missed
going out live we'll now go to item 3 on
our agenda
bc 2010 to confirm the minutes of the
annual meeting
held on 22nd september 2020
for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
council mulveezy are you um
pointing out an issue of accuracy with
the minutes
your hand is raised
okay thank you could i have a proposer
then
for the minutes please so
yes council beer can i have you got a
comment
no i i've moved the oh you're proposing
the minutes thank you
okay sorry
are you seconding your hand is raised
count counselor john osborne yeah i'm
happy to second madam chairman thank you
thank you thank you i'll now ask
the corporate manager governance and
civic office to conduct the electronic
vote thank you chair councillors could
you please open the vote in the
modern.gov app by clicking the plus sign
in the top right hand of the agenda
screen
and selecting attendance and voting in
the voting tab the vote for this agenda
item will show in blue
please click on the blue line to open
the vote thank you
councillors who still need to vote
councillor hinton councillor haran and
councillor lindsay
can you indicate councillors how you
wish to vote councillor hinton
uh in favor my modern gov screen's
completely frozen up won't move
okay thank you councillor haran yes i'm
sorry jam whatever i do the cursor does
not
come up but um i have read the minutes i
was at the meeting and i'm in favor of
agreeing them
okay thank you and counselor lindsay
for okay thank you
thank you that's 28 in favor and two
abstentions thank you very much
thank you the minutes of the meeting
have been confirmed
and will be signed at the next
practicable opportunity
we'll move now to item 4 on the agenda
bc 2011 announcements from the chairman
and leader
i refer you to paper bc 2011
for noting thank you council award do
you have anything to report
yes i do thanks madam chairman thank you
the second covered wave has now hit hard
and we are back in lockdown
things are different this time around
with fewer restrictions and the numbers
in suffolk
whilst fluctuating are still low
compared with the national picture
the latest data from the suffolk corona
watch site shows the east of england
currently has an estimated r value of
between one point naught and one point
three
here in baber there were 113 cases
reported in the past week which is a
rate of 120.6 per hundred thousand
in total we have had 925 confirmed cases
and sadly 63 deaths since the pandemic
began
although this latter number is the
latest data from the ons
and is only up to the 6th of november
however as i'm sure you are all aware we
do currently have a spike in hadley
and this is very concerning the current
weekly numbers for the town are 67 cases
which is a rate of a 601 per hundred
thousand
although extremely high it is thankfully
on the decline
whilst there has been a focus in the
press on the care homes and high school
household household transmission is also
taking place and we must continue with a
relentless public awareness and
messaging campaign
the stick with it suffolk campaign is
still active and the home but not alone
service has been reactivated
the advice for us all is to stay at home
as much as possible
but if we have to go out the message is
simple hands
face space use sanitizers where provided
in shops
wear a mask and maintain distance from
others
that way we can minimize transmission
and bring the infection rate down
we have started to distribute the latest
government business grants the local
restriction support grant and the
additional restrictions grant
we will also be renewing our response to
enable our homeless to have somewhere to
live through the winter
we are awaiting the government's
one-year spending review with a
statement due from the chancellor
tomorrow
whilst it remains disappointing that the
review won't provide longer-term
financial certainty
hopefully will include more support for
local authorities to address the very
significant
financial pressures we face and also
include the measures needed to provide
certainty for budget setting next year
we do have a significant budget
challenge at baber
and have started to consider measures we
will need to take to produce a balanced
budget for 2021 to 22
and provide a sound medium-term
financial strategy for the years beyond
to finish on an upbeat note the first
baba mid suffolk innovation awards were
held virtually on the 3rd in november
and were a great success in terms of
promoting innovation in the districts
although the technology had gremlins we
had 11 categories and there were
inspiring stories for each of the 28
finalists
so the winners were those that really
stood out
and finally today is counselor arthur's
birthday
so on behalf of the council i would like
to wish him a very happy
birthday thank you madam chairman
thank you um as
one of the ward members for hadley i
would also like to
add my concern for the
residents of hadley in particular and
i'd like to like to say
that for those people who have been
affected by
um this terrible pandemic um i and i'm
sure my fellow
hadley councillors and all members of
baber um have you in our thoughts and
we are all concerned for you thank you
and happy birthday to counselor arthy
we'll now move on back to the agenda
item five to receive notification of
petitions
in accordance with council procedural
rules
thank you chair none received thank you
item six questions by the public in
accordance with council procedural rules
none received chair item seven
questions by councillors in accordance
with council procedure
rules none received chair thank you
item eight bc 2012
overview and scrutiny committee report i
would like to invite council mccraw
to introduce paper bc 2012 which is for
noting
council macro thank you very much
chairman
um right i'm reporting on the meetings
held of the joint overview and scrutiny
committees
committee in september where two
meetings were held
on the 4th and the 22nd of september
i would note that these reports are for
information and for noting but i'm happy
to take any questions
on the content of the meeting so the
first item was a
future delivery model for our public
realm as councillors may be aware
the current contract for baber expires
in october
2021 and it's apparent that we would
need to make
new arrangements of the models we
examined
uh there were four of these to continue
as we were which would require
baber to obtain a new contract to bring
the services together
as mid-suffolk do in a single in-house
operation
to put both councils out to a new
contract
or to establish a wholly owned trading
company a latko
and deliver the services to both
councils in that manner
i'm glad to say that there was an
immense amount of information a very
well
prepared report from consultants from
outside the council i would add not at
great expense
we looked at everything and uh it was
fairly clear
that of the all the options and the time
limit allowing
that the recommendation should be for a
in-house operation
as it takes place in mid-suffolk we had
sufficient evidence of how well that
work went
and we're able to make comparisons with
our existing provision
we did feel that further work should be
undertaken in respect of developing some
kpis
um but finally the the option of having
a lat code be retained
as an option for the future for further
consideration
but given the time constraints probably
not right now
that recommendation went forward to
cabinet and i believe they have already
acted upon that
on the 21st of september we
considered a couple of items the first
or source three in fact the first of
these was the scrutiny
and first review of uh the baber mid
suffolk
uh housing test this is a complicated
one
delivery housing delivery test action
plan
these are separate documents for baber
and for mid suffolk
now this is not a statutory requirement
we are only required to
undertake this and once every five years
but as a matter of good practice
and also for good information the
councils have undertaken to carry this
out on an annual basis
so it was slightly delayed by covid19
but we were able to do it within a
reasonable time
frame and uh we noted the report the
appendices
and we're more than satisfied that the
housing delivery test action plan
is more than sufficient to our purpose
uh the annual review of sorry the screen
is moving too fast at times here
the annual review of the joint homes and
housing strategy
and homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping reduction strategy these are
really long titles i apologize for that
set out our vision for
um residents to be living comfortably
and safely
we've adopted these strategies in the
past we are updating them
and annually reviewing them uh we were
very impressed with the work
of the housing solutions team under
heather tucker our corporate manager
the challenges faced by that team during
covid
have obviously been most remarkable and
the speed of
response has been really quite
astonishing we made many thanks to the
officers
for the report the presentation and the
work
and we also made the particular point
that we believe that the committee
recognizing the importance of these
strategies
and stressed that housing continues to
be recognized by both cabinets
and by both councils as primary
functions
of a district council
a final item was dealt with on uh
independent living service
uh looking for a new model for disabled
facilities grant
now this was held in a confidential
section and the part two
of the local government act and
therefore uh i haven't
reported fully as much as i would like
to
i can assure you that we followed a
recommendation an option
contained within the paper
and that has gone forward to cabinet i
believe that
may still be under discussion either
with cabinet or with
employees who may be affected so
therefore i can't report greatly on that
until i'm given
the all clear that is entirely in the
public domain
what i will say is that the previously
existing
uh model had a lot of shortfalls that
overview and scrutiny had been pointing
out for the last two years
but the contract was fixed and was
required to con
complete um there were no advantages to
trying to leave it early
so it was left in place but interim
measures had been taken
to reduce the shortfall in our spend of
the available
disabled facilities grant members may
remember a year ago
that we made an extension and an
increase into the maximum
grant that could be given uh all i will
say apart from that is that
i think we're more than satisfied that
future provision for
our disabled facilities grant will be
far better
than we have had before i'm happy of
course to take any questions on this
report
either in the meeting or afterwards at
any time
thank you thank you councilman crore i
think we already have
um councillor hinton lined up for a
question
just a quick one looking at page 23 of
the papers
uh on which i think it's the first page
of the the report
that uh council mcgraw has just put
forward when talking about
the open space public realm
contracts etc or delivery models yes
towards the bottom of that page it talks
about the items that uh
that the plan the service covers
countryside amenity areas street scenes
a14 later picking playgrounds
public conveniences car parks no mention
of the a12
picking again this is not going to be
left off the contract somebody's going
to
have egg on their face it was not an
exclusive list
there were other items included in that
and obviously we i did we didn't want to
make the report any longer than it was
already
uh so yes um both everything that
covered by public realm
will was previously covered by public
realm will continue to be covered by
public realm
i'll just add that in whatever provision
is made
that a very very well thought out
transition plan
has been put in place to ensure
continuity
of service and for the residents
thank you council macro councillor
osborne council adrian osborne
yes thank you madam chairman it's um not
a question alistair
i just want to express my thanks and
that of of
i hope the committee uh that you uh
chair i think your chairmanship
chairmanship has been
absolutely excellent and bringing
together
all the points that uh have come up from
our overview and scrutiny
has been essential and those are the
teams that have
brought that to you and the witnesses
have done an
excellent job so thank you very much for
your chairmanship
i know you don't often you always thank
other people and i thought it was about
time that you got thanked as well
well we're blessed with thank you we're
blessed not only with good officers and
good teams but we're blessed with good
members
as a member of that committee also i
would like to support those
um the thanks to you uh
this is getting a little embarrassing
shall we move on please we'll move on
unless there further the questions um to
council macro
on this paper well if there are no more
questions
thank you very much councilman mccraw
and uh
that paper is for noting
we'll now move on to item 9
recommendations from
cabinet and committees
item 9a bc 2013
licensing act 2003
statement of licensing policy statutory
five-year adoption
i would like to invite councillor newman
to introduce paper bc
2013 and move the recommendation in the
report
councillor newman thank you madam
chairman
licensing act 2003 statement
of baby district council licensed policy
strategy five-year revision the
five-year review
of the statutory license policy for baby
district council has been carried out
it is for full council to decide whether
to adopt
revised policy the policy
consultation was carried out between the
20th of august 2020
and the 16th on the 16th of september
2020 in respect of the statutory license
policy for baby district council
the policy for baber and mid-suffolk are
broadly the same
apart from details relating to the
nature
of each district since
november 205 the licensing authorities
have been responsible for
functions under the license in act 2003
section 5 of the licensing act 2003
requires that each
licensed authority shall determine and
publish a local statement of licensing
policy
relating to discharge of licensing
functions under the act
the licensing team revised the statement
which has been
in effect since january 2016.
the report before you today seeks that
approval by full council or the revised
policy statement for baby district
council
so they may be adopted for publication
and ready to take effect from the 7th of
january 2021
the licensing team has undertaken the
necessary work within
existing resources and fee structure
the legalization aim the legislation
aims
to secure full cost recovery of the
administration
licensing act 2003 functions
though fees payable for license
applications
are ongoing maintenance the fees
banding system and fee levels are
currently set
by the general government via
regulations
as they have been unchanged since 2005
the previous government decided in early
2015
to not activate the provision of the
policy reform social
responsibility act 2011 section 121
which would have
devolved fee settings to the local
licensing authorities
the current draft will be the fifth
edition
of the council statement of licensing
policy under the licensing act
2003. the licensing team has the
necessary experience
stakeholder contacts and networking in
place
to ensure that the wide balance
consultes
has taken place the consultation took
place
over a period of four weeks though
through various channels and media
one response was received the lack
of response is not a concern to the
licensing team
as well as all existing premises and
clubs and licensing
over 500 150
sorry 150 relevant businesses
organizations were consulted including
all the parish councils the statement of
licensing policy
is based on the licensing act 2003
and the statutory guidance section 182
guidance
which limits degree of which it can be
amended there have been four previous
reviews
consultations and the policy have been
updated
and refined on each occasion it is
therefore
reasonable to assume that the consul ts
are satisfied
with the content
the draft statement of licensing policy
for baba was
considered by the licensing and
regulatory committee
on the 9th of october there were some
discussions
around the breadth of the consultation
and checks carried out to ensure that
the licensing application
have adequate english language skills
but not amended no amendments were made
and the committee voted unanimously
to recommend to full council that it be
adopted
without further amendment that concludes
my
summary if there are any questions i'll
be glad to answer them
if not the licensing officer catherine
greene can answer them
and i'd also like to thank my licensing
team who have worked very hard
during this covid so thank them very
much
over to you chair thank you councillor
newman
could i have a seconder please i'm happy
to second that chairman
thank you is that counselor carpendale
yes and i would also like to add my
thanks and appreciation to the work done
by the licensing team
they are extremely knowledgeable and
very helpful
thank you thank you well i'll now open
this up to questions
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under
discussion and must be a question
thank you robert lindsay councillor
lindsay have you got a question
yes i have thank you chair thank you um
and um councillor newman feel free to
tell me i'm completely off the beaten
track because i'm
i probably will be but i just wondered
if
um there was scope if the legislation
allows you scope to look at
um tightening up licensing a bit when
we're talking about
events that are giving out these sort of
single-use plastic cups and mugs and
things that just
tend to end up in the bushes um
it it i don't know if it was looked at
and it might be
impossible under the legislation it
it'd be nice to see us
licensing events where through the
licensing process
encouraging events to to actually use um
reusable plastic mugs so with a deposit
or something like that
so they have to be returned to the bar
or wherever they were
or got from is that is it was that
looked out and is that a possibility
i don't think that's been looked at
council lindsey but i'm sure um
catherine greene can back me up on this
but i'm sure that
when someone applies we couldn't say
what cups they can use but
i don't see why not we couldn't suggest
that they do
use plastic cups or recyclable cups
i've got no problem with that at all i
don't know if catherine green has got
anything to say on that matter
uh thank you council newman um quite
often um large-scale events come to our
safety advisory group
um so they're all go through um their
plans etc
in regards to um events so it's
something that we can
make sure that we advise um each and
every um
event that they should make sure that
they um
have that as a consideration okay thank
you catherine i think that is a good
idea and thank you robert lindsey
for your suggestion cancer rc
have you got a question um yeah thanks
yes just a quick one
um and it concerns the the list
um on page 34 of the papers which is
page four of the state
um and i just happened to notice that in
the list of premises where we have
issued licenses since the last review
the appearance of hairdressers and i
just wondered
what had changed for hairdressers to
need
to need a license i i was expecting this
question clive and it's a very good one
now um what they're doing hairdressers
do
weddings wedding hairstyles and they all
go in there
and they now like to offer them a drink
of champagne
actually in the deal with the hair but
obviously
they can't give drink with the hairdo
because they need a license for it so
that is why is now been added
thank you
thank you that was an interesting one
any more questions
any more questions please
thank you well if there's any no more
questions um
if they've finished we'll now move on to
debate um
counselors will only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes and this will be
timed
would anyone like to open the debate
please
[Applause]
would anyone like to open the debate on
on
this matter
so if there are no questions no further
questions and no debate
we'll now move straight on to the vote
counselor newman is there anything you'd
like to add though
first no i'd i'd like to move the
move the document and hope you'll vote
for it it's a very good document
it is indeed um i'll now ask the
corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote but first i'll
just for clarification read the
recommendation the recommendation
at 3.1 is that the draft revision
licensing act 2003
statement of licensing policy document
as attached
at appendix a to this report be adopted
for publication and to take effect for
five years
and if sooner revised from 7th january
2021 thank you so we'll now move to the
vote
thank you jen thank you chair um
councillors could you please open the
vote in the modern.gov app by clicking
the plus sign in top right hand of the
agenda screen
and selecting attendance and voting in
the voting tab the vote for this agenda
item will show in blue please click on
the blue line to open the vote
thank you
still waiting for cancer davis
councillor haran and councillor nunn
okay we are just waiting for cancer
horan and councillor nan
yes i'm sorry i don't seem to be able to
do it this time okay would you like to
to indicate how you wish to vote or
okay thank you and councillor haram
would you like to indicate how you wish
to vote
councillor haran are you able to
indicate whether you how you wish to
vote
okay um we will move to the vote and
without councillor horan's vote
at the moment okay thank you
chair that is 29 votes for thank you
thank you the merchant is carried
we'll now move to item 10 on the agenda
item bc 20
ict strategy i would like to invite
councillor parker
to introduce the ict strategy strategy
which is for comment only councillor
parker
thank you very much indeed uh madam
chair um
and in a moment i'll hand over to matt
harding who will take us
through a presentation of the it
strategy uh but before i do
madam chair i just wanted to try and add
some context for members so that we can
have a better understanding
around the object of the exercise so the
first thing to say
is that the ict strategy is all about
customer outcomes and less about
tech id it if you like is the conduit by
which we're able to deliver first class
customer outcomes
um as members will know rit is run in
conjunction with suffolk county council
this strategy helps us to unlock the
value in the existing partnership with
suffolk county council
just a quick word about how the strategy
came about in the formation of the
strategy
some time ago and indeed in the previous
administration it was recognized
that there needed to be a change in
provision of our ict
sarah wilcock who is our assistant
director for customers and digital
improvement
uh undertook some work to bring the
recommendations forward
and as a result of those recommendations
we restructured ict to bring the team
who look after our business applications
and bring them back into the council
uh enabling them to be closer to and
respond better to the needs
of the council with the addition of of
matt
our it corporate manager we've worked on
strengthening the relationship with
suffolk county to enable us to realize
the potential of that partnership but
moreover
really importantly the value that we can
extract from that partnership
and it's those steps that have provided
the foundations upon which this strategy
is built
so um so that gives a little bit of
background uh madam chair and
uh without further ado i'll hand over to
matt now to uh to give a brief
presentation and i'll i'll be happy to
to answer any questions if i can um
after matt's uh to set his space madam
chair thank you
thank you councillor parker thank you
chair and good evening councillors um i
am going to share my screen
uh to go through a brief presentation on
the ict strategy as councillor parker
has indicated so just bear with me one
second
please let me know if you cannot see the
screen
i am sharing
i am not sharing that's really helpful
okay can you see my screen
yes yes yes yes okay yes yes yes
yes right so thank you for that uh
just to go through it we're going to go
through the it strategy very high level
so i'm going to give you some it
the itc strategy overview and then i'll
hand back to council parker
to take comments as you will have seen
in the accompanying papers papers
our ict strategy is formed around four
creep
four key principles those are people
process
data and technology uh you'll
undoubtedly heard
until quite recently anyway the phrase
people process and technology
in terms of being the three key areas
from an ict perspective
that help to keep organizations
efficient and also ready to take full
advantage of any transformation
opportunities
another way of looking at these areas is
to look at them as key principles in the
successful
delivery of it something we want to do
in rit strategy
for instance if we don't involve people
or support them look at their processes
and understand them
we're not going to implement technology
that works for them it's quite simple
where is data in this however well
people and process both create and are
informed by data
and data is one of our potentially most
overlooked assets
and an asset that it can help surface
put in front of people
to provide them with the additional
insights that support their services
but also provide the evidence to the
organization
of the need for and the results of any
change
so with that in mind our strategy is
based on those four principles
to give you a little bit more detail
about those people
excuse me bear with me i'm just finding
that there we are people
is about connecting the staff of baber
district council with the information
and insight that enables them to
undertake their roles effectively
from wherever they may be something that
has become
vastly important during the covid crisis
but it's also about connecting the
residents and customers of baba to our
services in the most
and efficient way enabling them to
self-serve where appropriate
but not forgetting that everyone not
everyone can or will self-serve
it's about enabling the staff of baba to
collaborate across the organization
connecting those key strands of work
quickly and effectively
but also enabling that collaboration
across our partners and other delivery
agencies
it's about ensuring that key
communication tools are used by the
people and staff of babru
and are modern and fit for purpose but
it's ensuring that the communication
with our customers and partners as well
is relevant timely accurate and through
the relevant mediums and channels
process is about assessing our
technologies with a view to ensuring
they are enablers to effective processes
and efficient processes it's about
automating those processes where it
makes sense to do so
and leveraging our technologies that
help to digitally enable processes
within weber
we want to also automate those
repetitive sort of robotic tasks
that would then free our staff up to
focus on much more meaningful
and much more valuable tasks to both
them and our customer
and where a process can't be automated
end to end or it doesn't actually make
sense to do so
we want to look to accelerate those
parts of the process where it does make
sense
and can be done and can be done to
ensure that residents still get better
services
albeit potentially incrementally better
data is about ensuring that we utilize
technology to surface that data put it
in front of people
so that we can make it integral to the
day-to-day running of our business
we want to integrate those data sets
that help us to make informed
evidence-based decisions to improve
services and products
and we want to take the appropriate
opportunities that data provides us
both internally held data and externally
provided data to provide
insight into the potential future demand
for existing and or new services
in particular with data and actually all
of this it's
specific that we have to do this safely
and securely after all the data we hold
isn't ours but is that of our resident
and as such they expect that we are safe
stewards of it
technology is the last thing on my list
and now that may sound weird from an ict
strategy but as
councillor parker has said this is all
about ensuring outcomes for people
are those whether they be residents or
staff so from a technology perspective
we want to ensure that we are building
accuracy into the running of rit
services
enabling a proactive understanding of
the financial people and asset
implications of our technology service
we only want to exploit
appropriate new technologies whilst
leveraging
our existing technologies the things we
already have bought
to support the ambitions of baba and
improve the outcomes of our customer
for our customers finally i want to
deliver an i.t service
that is frankly aligned to the needs of
the services and staff and
of baber ensuring that it staff the i.t
staff of babe are engaged early and
often by services in their continuous
service improvement
so that's the four principles i just
want to give you a brief overview of how
that sort of a fits
in terms of a technical architecture
please be aware that this is not
a full technical architecture and is
only for the purposes of today
but to all intents and purposes how this
fits well i've talked about making sure
we get better outcomes for our residents
and as a result that basically means we
need to have products and services that
meet
residents needs our
services can be broken down from an it
perspective into sort of three key areas
what we would call the front office
that's the way that people contact us in
the main from an i.t perspective either
through telephony
or our online presence what we might
call our middle office which is the
stuff that enables people to take stuff
from online or web or telephone
and then put it into our backup office
system so for instance open housing
various other systems
our line of business systems by
implementing this strategy what we are
hoping to do
is we are hoping to ensure
that our front office
increases our customer engagement
enables us to reach more customers we
increase our self-service opportunities
but as i said earlier
we must remember i must be mindful that
there are some who are unable or
unwilling to take part in self-service
so we still need to provide
mediated access for them and we also
want to use our front office
area so our online forms and our
telephony channels to make sure that we
try and
start there for end-to-end digitization
of process
if we get the middle office right we
actually start to automate some of the
stuff that i've talked about earlier so
we
automate the stuff that people take out
manually and move in so if we automate
that we get better services we get
frankly quicker services
we also get increased data quality we
all make mistakes as humans when typing
things and it reduces the need for the
staff in the middle office to do that
sort of repetitive robotic work work
and enables them to do more meaningful
and more frankly
fun tasks for them and then if we get
the
third area right which is our line of
business systems we end up with systems
that are much easier to use
they are fit for purpose they are modern
and they are accessible from anywhere
and also we start to understand their
service cost so we understand
the cost potentially of individual
pieces of service being delivered to
individual members of the public
or residents providing us with far
greater data
that data is massively important by
being able to
flow this all through an automated way
or a better way in terms of integration
we start to get much greater data in the
data warehouse
that provides that enables us to provide
descriptive analytics
and by descriptive analytics i simply
mean that provides us to be able to
sorry that puts us in a position to be
able to provide
real-time dashboards of data that
describes
what is happening now and because
they're real-time dashboards
and they are automated it reduces the
time in data provisioning and
manipulation of that data outside
by staff in fact it means that they can
get on with the delivery of service
rather than necessarily trying to
understand what is happening all the
time
finally if we then bring external data
sources into that we can start moving
towards predictive analytics
in other words starting to understand
what might happen
that linked with our what is happening
provides us with an evidence base that
is absolutely vital
to enabling us to provide better
designed and commissioned services and
products
which are evidence-based and potentially
demand predicted products and services
that meet residents needs
products and services that provide
better outcomes for residents
and with that i will hand over back to
councillor
parker for comments
super job thank you very much indeed um
matt for that and as you know as we said
at the outset it can be quite a heavy
topic
uh and and it can at first glance be a
or appear to be a bit of a dry subject
but but
the uh the architecture that sits behind
uh is absolutely crucial to delivering
what we want to deliver in the future
for you know for our
uh for our customers and that's that's
our constituents and that's everybody
that uses the service so
happy to take any questions um uh madam
chair uh
obviously this item isn't for voting on
particularly so um i have to take any
questions
thank you thank you councillor parker
that was really interesting presentation
um councilor mabry i think you have
question
or comment yes thank you um
and i would like to direct this to um
our officer matthew harding
considering that my children and perhaps
even my grandchildren
think that granny is a technophobe i
actually understood that so well done
um my comment to you is and
it's raised its ugly head again
for me this week is i hope that when
this is all being designed and you are
collating data and using it
in a better form my words not yours
um that you will actually take note of
um deceased residents
um this has been a theme of mine uh for
a while
that the message doesn't always get down
to the people that it should
that someone is deceased that they
are receiving information for a variety
of reasons
um including this week um
i think it was something to do with a
parish councillor
so i hope that that is taken on board
thank you
thank you councillor mayberry uh where
we have access to that data
and ready access to that data then we
should be able to make sure it is
integrated
please be aware though that in some
instances we don't collate that data
we would have to get it from a third
party and there are lags
in terms of time scale of that data so
there will still be at times
difficulties in making sure that we are
aware from a timeliness perspective
um madam chairman may i come back on
that one please
yes you can um thank you um
this has been an issue and our chief
executive is very aware
um and i have um written to him on
numerous occasions
and there are hopefully stricter sort of
policies
for this however it
does still seem as though sometimes
these subjects are put forward
to the council and it's not always
accepted and i'm hoping that with your
predictive
uh data that you're talking about um
that
it can be that you have noticed that
somebody is deceased
so there's no point in sending them
thank you councillor mabry we'll now
move on to
the next question from councillor
jameson
okay thank you chair um i'm not sure
who this goes to but um in terms of the
i know you this is more
the strategy than the itiers council
parker mentioned
um but in terms of i.t do we know the
carbon footprint of the hardware and
architecture that
we is um used to support these services
in terms of
storage and um
that the uh servers and other hardware
and are we doing anything to improve the
efficiency of this
kit thank you
i'm happy to defer that question uh
council jameson over to
uh matt if if we may thank you
uh the short answer council jameson is
no we don't yet uh but we are in the
process
alongside our biodiversity action plan
and our green
agenda to start understanding that
better we do have a lot
of services that are outsourced so to
all intents and purposes we have
cloud-based services
externally i am aware that some of the
big vendors and one of those
particularly that we use a lot in fact
we're using their
technology right now to hold this
meeting microsoft are
currently trialling uh an online tool
set that will allow us to understand
exactly how much
co2 we are creating as a result of these
tool sets
the one thing i would say however is
that we are creating probably far less
by being able to do this remotely than
we would all be if we were driving to
and from
the council office yeah okay
thank you council award
thank you madam chairman um firstly i
will take
a issue councillor parker this is not a
dry subject
it used to be my bread and butter it's
um it's
it's actually very interesting and and
uh i think this
strategy document is is excellent um
the the conceptual architecture that uh
matt
outlined is uh makes a lot of sense it's
it's
easy to understand and it's the right
direction that
all organizations public or private
sector should should be following
i'm particularly pleased about the focus
on on data
and making sure that that is right and
shared um
and that it becomes more than data it's
information
and um particularly so that we can use
it properly
to get good analytics and and uh
dashboards
um for all of our service areas and i
think that's great
um just just one further comment uh um
on councillor jameson's uh question
about the carbon footprint
one of the benefits of course of of uh
cloud
uh computing and um sharing resources
like that is you do not have to rely on
your
own physical infrastructure
you share the infrastructure with with
other users
the the focus is on virtualization you
have virtual servers which you spin
up as and when you require them to to
meet the demand
the storage is is much more efficiently
shared
so um yeah we do need to keep a focus on
on on the carbon footprint and and then
microsoft
and other vendors uh in terms of their
their um uh facilities they're gonna
bring
into play to allow that to be monitored
will be very helpful but
um uh the strategy is one that that does
does um help with the the um the carbon
footprint greatly
so i'm very pleased with this and uh i
think
it's it's an excellent way forward so um
that's that's
um fine with me thank you madam chairman
thank you council ward councillor bosby
i'm sorry about that on the other hand
we've been talking about getting our
data right for
i don't know 12 years i think
haven't we lee and
sales just about every government
department and
just about every government department
has screwed up on this
what confidence can we have that we are
going to be getting it
correct uh
i'll i'll answer that one um uh council
busby and i
i think uh the very facts uh
that we for example we are we're sitting
here doing this now
virtually as we are um uh
means that certainly baby mid suffolk is
very serious
about its uh about its ict i understand
that we were one of the first councils
actually to
uh you know to be doing public meetings
etc but
around that specific um point around
data that
i suppose the point is this is the whole
point of this presentation to you this
evening we now
have a strategy uh and that was the that
was the key item that was missing
previously
uh it's you know matt will be able to
explain far more than i will that it
hitherto it's always been a sort of a
mashing together
of all sorts of strains of
i.t from from all manner of sources we
now have a strategy that we can follow
and
and and bring it all under one roof um
that that strategy of course
it's um it never finishes it it
continues i think that's that's a really
important point as well
um matt can i bring you in on that just
to um just to explain
really briefly um uh or or to
expand a bit further on that yes
certainly uh and i'll go back to
something that council award mentioned
actually which is around
uh cloud-based services and the fact
that to all intents and
purposes the the power that we can now
throw quite easily at data that we
weren't able
to before because we were limited by our
own data centers by
smaller processors by a whole load of
other things that basically made it
quite difficult and quite a
very time consuming job to to mash up
that data to mix that
data together is now something that can
be done much quicker
much more efficiently at the press of a
button so
to all intents and purposes whilst the
confidence is there that we can start to
surface that data we can start to join
that data up quicker we can also start
therefore to understand
where we need to improve it quicker so
really the confidence is there that
we're on the right journey now i think
is the way to describe it
and it is it is i mean 12 years ago
business intelligence tool sets the tool
sets that we will be using to surface
this data were very much in their
infancy they weren't necessarily mature
tool sets and they certainly weren't
tool sets that were in the fingers
at the hands of everybody to be able to
use and i think that's made a
significant shift
in terms of the confidence being able to
make things better in terms of data
okay thank you uh i certainly have more
confidence this time than we did when we
spent a million pounds with a canadian
set of consultants but as we're only two
minutes away from clive's cottage pie i
won't say anything
thank you councilman mccraw
thank you chairman um i'd like to thank
matthew for putting forward a difficult
job
at translating technological
architecture
into human speak is never easy and in
fact i don't think it's actually
fully achievable but the systems
and the care in creating those is
something i do understand there's a
misspent life in gaming
uh simulations uh war games whatever
um i've even designed a few and the
point of got this is care
because it's the care in creation it's
the key the human element
here is the purpose not the
technological uh
all the successful advances in it uh
in the use of in the internet age of
apps of
smartphones the keys have always been
the ones that have been successful have
always been those that are intuitive
people understand exactly what to do
because the
the design has been done in such a way
as to make it obvious and easy
and and i i appreciate there's been
criticism in the past of it systems
i have noted over the years that the uh
intuitiveness of
gov dot uk has improved out of all
recognition uh the difficulty in
obtaining a licensed renewal or
anything online uh used to be very
difficult it's not difficult now at all
literally you press a button you enter a
number and
it goes through um we have to be looking
for
yeah we're looking for an instinct to
apply for make it
as easy as possible for people we're
designing this for ease
and that's the only comment i'd make is
that we'll we should be looking if
anything
for intuitive understanding
without needing too much explanation
um it's a very interesting piece of work
thank you and i also like the fact
that uh baber and mid suffolk will not
be wholly reliant
on the provision of service from scc
that we actually have a strategy
and a direction in which to go where we
are not just subservient clients
we actually have an idea of what it is
we want
and i hope there'll also be some
economies involved in that
thank you council mccraw have you got
anything you'd like to reply
with regard to that council parker well
just on that specific point i think
councilman cora has absolutely hit the
nail on the head with all of that and
that that it's a really really good
understanding of exactly what
the strategy is all about and and i just
reiterate again that ultimately this is
about customer outcomes this is about
providing
the very best services for for our
constituents to be able to access is
um at whatever time they choose to
access so
appreciate the comments thank you madam
chair thank you
are there any other comments that any
members would like to make
so if there are no further comments um
is there anything further something up
that you'd like to do or
oh um
no no thank you very much for your
attention and thank you very much as
well to uh to matt
thank you thank you councillor parker
um so that report was for comment only
now we'll move on to the last item on
our agenda item 11
counselor appointments are there any
changes to placings
council award
not this time thank you madam chairman
thank you
so if there's nothing further i'll now
look to close the meeting
um the date of the next meeting
is tuesday 19th of january
2021 can you believe
so um if there's nothing else
i'd like to wish you all a very happy
christmas i think it might be a slightly
different one from normal
i hope you all stay healthy and all your
families and friends stay healthy and as
many of our residents
as possible stay healthy and
i wish you all a very happy christmas
and a good new year and i look forward
to seeing you
all in january thank you
you